.
>> THEY DID SAY IT WAS SORENESS
WITH JOEL'S RIGHT KNEE.
DID YOU RULE OUT SOMETHING
REALLY SERIOUS?
>> I REALLY DON'T KNOW.
I KNOW THEY'RE PROBABLY GOING TO
DO IMAGING TOMORROW AS A
PRECAUTIONARY.
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
>> WHEN JOEL IS IN TROUBLE, AND
GONE, AND FANS WANT BEN TO SAVE
THE DAY, BECAUSE THEY LOOK AT
HIM AS THE OTHER CORNERSTONE, IS
THAT FAIR FOR THEM TO SEE IT
THAT WAY?
>> NO.
BUT YOU GUYS KEEP THIS BEN
SIMMONS NARRATIVE ALIVE, WHICH
TO ME IS FREAKING INSANE HOW
GOOD THIS GUY IS, ALL THE THINGS
HE DOES.
BEN IS NOT A 40-POINT GUY.
HE DOES OTHER THINGS FOR YOUR
TEAM.
AND I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
THAT'S NOT SINKING IN IN OUR
CITY.
I DIDN'T THINK HE WAS SCARED OF
THE MOMENT.
HE JUST DIDN'T MAKE THEM.
SO AGAIN, WITH BEN, WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP HIM ON THE FLOOR.
UNLESS YOU GUYS WANT US TO BENCH
HIM THE WHOLE GAME.
IF ANYBODY WANTS US TO DO THAT,
JUST LET ME KNOW.
THEN I'LL KNOW YOU DON'T KNOW
BASKETBALL.
>> A LITTLE SALTY IN THE
POSTGAME.
I WAS LISTENING TO IT AS IT WAS
HAPPENING, AND DOC WAS TIRING OF
THAT LINE OF QUESTIONING ON BEN
SIMMONS.
HOW BIG A FACTOR CAN THIS BE
GOING FORWARD IN THE SERIES?
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY GAMES MORE
IT'S GOING TO BE.
THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO WIN AT
HOME AND END THIS THING.
BUT IS IT A THING RIGHT NOW?
>> I THINK DOC MADE GREAT POINTS
ABOUT BEN DOES SO MANY THINGS.
BUT I THINK THIS COULD BE A HUGE
FACTOR.
BEN IS YOUR PLAYMAKER, YOUR BEST
ONE.
IN THE LAST TWO MINUTES, IF YOU
DON'T WANT TO GIVE HIM THE BALL
BECAUSE YOU THINK THEY'RE GOING
TO FOUL HIM, YOU HAVE GUYS ON
THE COURT MAKING PLAYS, AND HE'S
THE BEST DECISION MAKER.
>> 100%.
WHEN THEY USED TO FOUL SHAQ OR
DWIGHT HOWARD, TOTALLY
DIFFERENT.
BECAUSE THOSE TWO GUYS HAVE TO
BE GIVEN THE BALL.
BEN SIMMONS HAS THE BALL.
SO YOU CAN FOUL HIM.
AND HE HAS TO MAKE FREE THROWS.
END OF STORY.
BECAUSE IF DOC SAYS HE'S GOING
TO KEEP HIM IN, HE HAS TO HIT
FREE THROWS TO WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP.
BECAUSE THE DIFFERENCE IS,
AGAIN, THOSE TWO GUYS HAVE TO BE
GIVEN THE BALL.
ONE GUY HAS THE BALL.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, WHEN HE HAS
IT, AND AS HE'S MAKING PLAYS,
YOU KNOW, SHAQ IS A FINISHER.
DWIGHT HOWARD IS A FINISHER.
SO NOW YOU ARE TAKING TWO THINGS
AWAY FROM -- PLAY MAKING
ABILITY, AND HE'S NOT SHOOTING
FREE THROWS, AND HE'S A
FINISHER.
ALL THREE ARE NOT HAPPENING.
WITH SHAQ, IT'S LIKE, THEY'RE
FOULING HIM.
BUT THEY'RE NOT STOPPING HIM
FROM FINISHING IF HE WANTED TO
FINISH WHEN HE HAS THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES.
IT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT ANIMAL.
>> I'VE SAID IT BEFORE AND I'LL
STICK WITH IT.
BEN SIMMONS IS AN ALL-STAR, A
TERRIFIC PLAYER, HE CAN'T BE A
SUPERSTAR UNTIL HE LEARNS TO
SHOOT THE BALL AND FREE THROWS.
HE DOES GREAT THINGS.
BUT I DON'T THINK ANY PLAYER CAN
BE A SUPERSTAR IF THEY CAN'T
SHOOT, ATTEMPT SHOTS.
BUT ALSO, IF HE'S GOING TO MISS
THOSE FREE THROWS, T